the NASCAR seasons February to November
it's long it's a grueling season every
weekend we race it's very important that
before the season starts before we go to
Daytona we go through the hauler check
everything out
go outside set up the pit box break it
down a few times make sure everything's
in order before we hit the racetrack so
that's the hauler for the number 18
that's where we keep our race cars
that's where we keep all of our tools
for everything we need to work on the
racecars once we get to the racetrack
each weekend we bring four haulers to
the racetrack all four haulers have to
3,500 pound cars also all four haulers
have about 10,000 pounds of gear once we
get to the racetrack you have about
anywhere from 12 to 15 crew guys that
work on and off the hauler and then also
work on the pit box we're in the garage
we're gonna get a tour of the number 18
race hauler we call it the race hauler
because it hauls the tools and the cars
to the racetrack let's go inside and
take a look as we step through this side
door we'll go up into the lounge up here
is where the crew chief and engineers go
over everything pre-race practice and
qualifying and they come up with the
best game plan for us to be successful
on Sunday if you turn around and take a
look you'll see this is where we house
the cars we push them onto the lift gate
and they get slid up top and tied down
we walk through the hallway here you'll
notice this thing is a giant toolbox it
is a race shop on wheels everything we
need to be successful on Sunday is
housed here we could build a race car
from start to finish with all the tools
that are in these drawers everything we
need
zip ties the clamps all the drivers
needs anything in the interior of the
car everything is on here and everything
is labeled these guys can run on the
hall or grab what they need get back to
work very fast walk down the hallway
here take a look at the jerseys as the
crews jump off the wall they go over the
wall and work on the car they have to be
in these viruses these guys wear these
to protect themselves
[Music]
the number one means the communication
at the racetrack our radios
everybody's got a radio and they're all
labeled guys you go over the wall then
wear these custom ear molds and then
their helmets go on top guys that are up
top on the pit box they wear these over
the ear and they have mics so they call
in the place whatever the pit stop is
going to be if we walk out back here
you're gonna run into the lift gate so
let's take a look take this up daddy
all right we're riding the lift gate up
top so we can push the car on top of the
hauler
we got Montana and slim helping us out
both of our truck drivers they do this
every week with two race cars as we get
to the top it'll be just enough room
[Music]
the cars loaded up the haulers ready to
go now we're gonna go take a look at the
pit box the pit box is essentially a
giant toolbox that we actually move on
to pit road and we work off of it once
the race starts setting up the pit box
is a process that we do 36 weekends out
of the year
it comes closed down with a cover on top
the first thing we do is we'll take the
cover off we have a lift gate where the
benches go so we lift the lift gate up
we put the ladder up we set up the front
monitors we double check all the drawers
to make sure all of our tools are there
everything's in place we get all of our
tires set they go around that what we
have to do with those blank tires it's
just a blank rim what we have to do is
take our lug nuts we blew them up and we
stick them on top of the rim that will
sit for about three hours and then about
thirty minutes before the race start
we'll double-check those you might also
see some changers using their air guns
on our practice of that's located on the
side of the pit box the last thing we
want is to be unprepared when we get to
the racetrack so each week we go through
all of these drawers to make sure we
have all of our tape all of our
screwdrivers our hammers we got a
cabinet full of reciprocating saws in
case we got to cut fenders off like I
said before we have the tape so we can
fix the fenders if we do some bumping
out there on the racetrack we got our
drills I talked about hammers earlier we
got hammers to beat and bang the fenders
in this is the front part of the pit box
it'll line right up to pit wall so when
we're up on pit wall if there's
something we need at the last second we
can just reach right here grab it and
then go work on the car we've got sign
poles that hang out over the front of
the pit box so when the driver comes
down pit road he knows which stall to
pull into next to those sign poles are
also GoPros different cameras so they
can film the pit stop as we're changing
the tires we have these monitors here
and then we're in the computers and
they're all linked up to those cameras
so we can come back after the stop and
we can review hey what happened there
what went wrong was that the drivers
fault was at our fault we also have
these different cabinets loaded full of
medical supplies
if anything happens during the pit stop
we can come here and grab what we need
the last part of the pit box is probably
going up top to show you where our
sponsors sit or where the rest of the
team guys sit we have all these monitors
here
chief kar Chief Engineers they're all
sitting up here sort of calling the
plays if you will as the race is taking
place also when the car hits pit road
they have a bird's-eye view right down
onto the pit stop so they can see what
goes wrong if the driver asks so
typically our crew chief will get on the
radio and he'll call us up on the wall
and say hey guys be ready in about two
laps we're gonna do a pit stop so we'll
grab our tires will step up on the wall
we'll grab our air guns we'll grab our
jacks and we'll just get ready we kind
of get set when he's one pit stall away
that's when we can jump over the wall so
we're anywhere from 11 to about 13
seconds for a four tire exchange we
start on the right side first we
exchange the tires then we transition to
the left side exchange the tires
all the while we'll fuel in the car
wiping it clean off the grill to make
sure it's not overheating and then we
send it on its way once all the lug nuts
are tight
stocking the hauler setting up the pit
box gluing up tires practicing warming
up this is how we prepare every weekend
for the race